while clark county firefighters training
to respond to horrific car wrecks today
they practice how to actually extract
people who are trapped after a crash 8
news now reporter victoria saha got a
front row seat
they are ready for anything but the
first thing after arriving to a crash is
to stabilize the car then they will make
their way inside i'm going to cover you
with this blanket okay it's going to
protect you for breaking glass metal
next they'll use the jaws of life to pry
open the doors and use a belt cutter to
get a victim out of their seat belt and
if you're a bystander jumping in to help
it's important to not move the victim
you know not they're not going to be
able to tell this for sure has a spinal
injury
but that's why you know even for us we
don't start touching people until we can
confirm
a b and c
what's going on and fiery crashes always
intensified the situation bystanders
couldn't get to tina tinter and her dog
max the car they were in caught fire
after a vehicle allegedly driven by
henry ruggs slammed into them at a
higher rate of speed people did try to
help
and the environment changed
flames heat smoke and their body told
them to get away deputy chief warren
whitney addressed recent criticism from
ruggs's lawyer saying firefighters did
everything they could unless there
happened to be an engine right there on
the corner when it happens i mean then
we could have suppressed the fire and
extricated her victoria saha live local
now
deputy chief whitney says deputy chief
whitney says a car fire needs three
things it needs fuel oxygen and an
ignition source which tinder's car had
after it was hit so the flames just kept
reigniting fire officials say really the
best way you can help is be as detailed
as possible when you're calling 911
giving them those directions and if
there is no immediate danger then you
can use a belt cutter or a window
breaker that's kind of a little gadget
you can pick up at an auto parts or a
home improvement store and just keep it
in your car